blow take it alert gang get your tickets
to The Gramercy theater and come out and
see the boys February 3rd yeah gang it's
our third show we added the Army garbage
came out strong sold out the first two
we added a third let's sell this last
one out we love yous let's do it welcome
so another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage you ain't lying it's
a little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy yeah or if they're
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at Aunt
Cody's basement she's upstairs watching
that Yellowstone prequel what is it 1823
I think so topless okay a little strange
but what are you gonna do my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and my best
pal give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
hey what's up gang uh thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe over there on iTunes
full video available YouTube as you know
those numbers are true
and obviously the greatest website of
all time www.patreon.com
ayg are you garbage sorry uh you sign up
your bonus episodes ayg you get episodes
on hard feelings we got a ton of of bad
behind the scenes footage from the tour
US Travel new guy Luke just threw one up
the other day it's us cooking breakfast
up there in Rhode Island I mean you go
to a stop and shop kid it's a good time
it's a good time some sausage some bacon
we do it was a good time over there
we're having a party stop being a bozo
be a homie somebody commented we do have
a good time out on the road it's fun to
be together we do yeah they're meeting
the folks getting around going town to
town a couple of bears couple of burning
a couple of beers
a couple of bowls of chili for the big
man
nothing but all that how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works those ones and twos
crosses them T's and dots to him eyes I
think he's responsible with his ice cold
and Diet Mountain Dew I got in my hand
God damn it son would you get that from
Antarctica t-ball McMuffin Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes what's up
t-bas nothing I'm also responsible for
kippy's lukewarm water oh man he teased
me without he teased me with a screamer
I chugged it and then needed one for the
episode Jesus Christ those things were
on [ __ ] Mars that [ __ ] college boy
over there that's the that's the
employee of the month right there yeah
she's working overtime uh she needs a
raise she's got an iceberg up top though
oh yeah oh yeah freezer you can barely
put a candy bar in there that freezer is
just getting smaller and smaller by this
that's why you want it though yeah but
where you can't put nothing in there and
I don't know how to what do you chisel
it out we're gonna have a goddamn leak
in here you have to unplug it let it sit
for a little while yeah then it's all
then it melts though right put a bucket
underneath it or a tarp a tarp put a
tarp on it who's got a tarp I got a tarp
where
there's a tarp in that closet over there
okay we're just making stuff up welcome
back to the make stuff up show folks
next to my squirrel suit
um you never had that as a kid right
squirrel suit no I never had one no uh I
always wanted one though your fridge
never did that right you weren't
we had a leaky fridge not a leaky fridge
but you never had to defrost the freezer
uh-uh that's College that's maybe
grandparents house that's like older
appliances I feel though that's an ice
box yeah that's a nice that's you gotta
do that to the ice box we never had I
don't think our first of all I don't
think our freezer got that cold for that
to be a problem our Lego waffles were
about room temp no butter right on them
yeah my grandmother had an old fridge
like that he had a melder you had to
stall her out come springtime he had a
melter out come around Springtime and
it's funny the we were kind of talking
about this the other day the
refrigerator at your parents house gets
to a certain point where it's you know
it's a number one show on TV it's
fantastic but then it starts going down
the hill again it's like a piece of
fruit it's good it's good for a little
while and she gets banged one of them
goes or whatever but then when it gets
the worst is
the grandmom fridge is a real tough look
my grandmother I know but that's your
mom now nah nah but it's not that bad it
is back in the day it was worse my mom's
is cuckoo bananas I was just down there
last week do you sure trust the goddamn
thing I know we were talking about that
but the lights in I'm talking the light
doesn't work that when you were a little
kid and you would open like your great
aunt or like you know your your
grandmother's refrigerator and you were
scared to put your hands
Rattler jump out and get you hey hey
funny coleslaw smell coming out oh yeah
um we have for the longest time are
refrigerator uh because the house was
new when we moved in but then that's
when like you know the divorce happened
things got tight the whole night and
they they just replaced all the
appliances maybe a couple of years ago
so they lasted like 30 something years
but through all of high school I would
say Junior High in high school the light
didn't work no the fridge door had like
oh yeah fell so you'd have to lift it up
flick it back in there was a note too
for guests you know what I mean like hey
you gotta lifter and twister all right
don't go rooting the ball game start
just start throwing a Macarena to close
this goddamn thing that's like going to
your homie's place he's got the note on
the toilet like you just gotta lift the
top you gotta jiggle it never understood
that lifting the top of a tank and I I
would try to like yeah you just gotta
jiggle that I don't know what I was
jiggling you didn't stick in your I know
it's clean water because my family's
from Plumbing but a stick in my hand in
a tank irks me you're trying to catch
the flap to make sure it lifts up I know
but it never just stops there I don't
know I I don't know sometimes the flap
didn't close and we get hung up on some
are you one of those families that had a
brick in there uh we had to bring a
couple of boxes we had a brick in there
what can that save you oh Toby Google
what can a brick and a toilet save you a
year It's gotta be
13 we also had a paper clip that was
hooked on to the thing [ __ ] MacGyver
take a dookie
cut the red wire huh Patty yeah there
was something wrong with talking about
blowing up the bed
there was something wrong with it yeah
so she just put the paper clip it like
came up came apart it saves you
0.25 gallons per flush so quarter gal a
quarter again go that's all right hands
up yeah but then you hop in a shower you
take a 25 minute shower it's all I mean
what are we doing here stretch it out
yeah my wife does that she's like you
used too much water when you're doing
the dishes and she'll jump in the shower
for about three four days what the [ __ ]
worried about worried about me doing the
doing the pots and pans here how do you
have finger problems how do you feel
about sleeping with the lights on is
that trashy I feel like that's a garbage
I sleep
I don't get as good a good night's sleep
I'm so my wife's been my wife's I always
away visiting friends in down there and
flow right scared her ah no in The Burbs
dude I'm I I'd have to get like a tank
if I move out to The Burbs I'd have to
have like an outpost of people watching
and [ __ ] why you're safer out there
quieter there's a lot more ways to get
in the house too but my apartment
there's one way in one way out baby and
plus I got anzi Ponzi shamalamadanza you
know cause a gauntlet baby yeah dude one
way in trying to do any I mean like you
do the burbs it's wide open down it's a
lot of ground to cover it's a lot of
ground because especially if you're in
that house by yourself talk about
keeping your head on us nothing goddamn
Exorcist nothing scares me more than the
sliding glass door baby look out that's
where the Lopper comes in
I was sleeping on the couch at my mom's
last week and my brother-in-law came
over and he was coming on the back in
the morning now it was like I don't know
seven or whatever
and it was like in the mornings like
seven in the morning he had to come over
to drop something off her picks he was
doing wait hold on I know this house
where are you again I'm on the couch in
the living room yeah oh you're a
direction oh man a lot of Windows in
there to get God too
so uh
can you turn your back to the sliding
glass door and go into the how about a
sliding glass door but they look like it
they're all windows yeah we're like an
Open Door yeah yeah okay but I see feet
like because like the they're like big
window and they're drawn like you know
three people under the couch no like
three quarters of the way down [ __ ]
Kevin McAllister over here dude so I
just see feet on the deck and that noise
like a deck rattling you're all you're a
dude you [ __ ] you're up and you're
I'm I jumped up and then Hans got scared
I got more scare we're both barking it's
a scene you're going at it with a butter
knife with jelly on it yeah come here
son of a [ __ ] well get me a lender's
Bagel while you're at it uh yeah I I'm
not I always say I want to move to The
Burbs but I don't know if I'm cut out
for I'm a big [ __ ] it's just not what
I'm used to I'm used to give me a
crackhead give me a crazy guy on the
subway I can navigate that
I'm in The Burbs and it's quiet and it's
you know or even down the shore off
season anywhere where there's not a lot
of people uh-uh can't be fighting Skin
Walkers
some demons out there yeah no way it's a
Jersey Devil I don't like that
I can't I can't I can't I can't get
bloody mary an uppercut
go right through her yeah no I don't I
but so I was away my my wife's been away
so I've been I slept on the couch for
the past like three days so good for you
dude I know but I like the TV you got I
thought you didn't have a TV you got the
frame baby we've gone over this all the
time oh that's right that was like three
years ago I keep forgetting yeah and I I
got him out there we hang we watched
Seinfeld together leave the lights on no
but I leave that TV on all night and
it's bright dude it's like that and just
I like leaving last night you wake up
with some old 80s actor selling you gold
trying to get me term life insurance or
Sam Waterston trying to give me a
reverse mortgage Tom saw him trying to
take your house
no so do we uh the perfect and I found
out last night I got up to get up to
tinkle maybe call like two three o'clock
in the morning sure get up to Tanki and
uh
Netflix asked me am I still watching so
the screen's darker but that's the
perfect amount of light I need some
light
so it's like you know blacked out a
little bit and you have enough to
illuminate the room but it's still
enough that it's gonna let you get a get
some good shutout you know let me ask
you this ask me bud what the [ __ ] did I
care how about Netflix how about you
mind your own [ __ ] business you're
still getting the seven bucks a month
aren't you then play it yeah if I'm
still paying I'm still one I want it
played I don't need you yeah I'm [ __ ]
watching it uh-huh
keep it going I understand but it's
gotta be some sort of metric they're
working with what's in it for them [ __ ]
today find out how things perform I
don't Hey listen it's Seinfeld we like
it all right just leave it up keep it
cooking I've walked two mean Hans big
kruck and Seinfeld like five seasons I
mean [ __ ] drives me crazy are you still
watching yeah [ __ ] told a check
bounces I'm still [ __ ] watching yeah
now let's go I I have a question for you
fellas I'm listening please I got a new
phone and I got no new case for it
though [ __ ] that's right so I'm walking
around I feel like an astronaut with no
case yeah it but it you need a case
because I'm gonna destroy it but what do
you think is the class you think case is
classier or no case what do you what but
are you nuts I think that's a Jihad you
got in your hand there yeah dumbass oh I
got the Plus
theft and loss let me see that [ __ ]
case you lost it okay insurance fraud
people I gotta teach this goddamn guy
everything be a cool guy without a case
that's what I would do I mean CVS is by
your apartment huh oh yeah there you go
go in there you take a header over some
cheese balls or something like that fall
into the pharmacy bring this soup you
know you got to get one of those
OtterBoxes oh get the heavy bite that
comes with spackle on your jeans right
away one of those guys dude you ever see
a guy a guy that [ __ ] got real hot for
him who hands you an OtterBox has paint
on his hands when it comes to you it's
just like it's like it ever did yeah use
my phone it's the size of a textbook
yeah exactly and it's got like the hard
plastic on the screen it's like Plexi
Clips yeah yeah you're like what are you
doing it's like an old ATM trying to
[ __ ] put the numbers on let me see
the phone hold it up it's the same one
you got
oh that's it oh well no I gotta upgrade
one of the [ __ ] bozo yeah no kidding
um why didn't you buy a case when you
bought the phone I never understand
people because I want a wallet that's
built into the case okay they don't have
that at the [ __ ] Verizon store no New
York City no not a lot of times no they
want you to have the [ __ ] mugger
special it's just magnetized things will
fall off I don't trust it yeah no they
just got a regular case for for for the
time being did you order a case I've
been poking around but they all suck
this guy dude anything it's raw dog yeah
yeah no [ __ ] you just want to protect it
in case you [ __ ] drop it I do I do
pull it out and it feels like I'm gonna
get pregnant and the insurance and of
this and that and the stolen whatever
yeah that's great but that don't help
you in the moment when you drop that
[ __ ] [ __ ] walking down the street and
you're hemmed up what are you gonna do
then
[ __ ] broken ass phone I would love to
hear that I'd love to hear in the
YouTube comments how many people have a
cracked screen right now I feel like
that's a thing of the past a little bit
though right 100 I feel like they've
gotten better either the technology is
better they're better at fixing them at
one point 98 of iPhone screens were
crashed sure my I used to mine was so
bad a glass would go in my ear yeah call
people sliced up yeah [ __ ] swiping
slice ship slice up your finger I've
done a lot of research in the real world
with our fans working the merch table at
the live shows a lot of venmos from
crack screen cracks right yeah
yeah once you upgrade though you're good
because they give those uh
[ __ ] glass on it yes remember that doing
that technology came out it was like I
remember brag something I was somebody
was bragging to me what's that called or
something it's called something Toby
what's that called the guy was I think
it was screened on the screen screen
protector yes there you go hey Elon
yikes
almost seems too easy huh
my brother's like Shelly he's like not
is there's tiny layer of Glass on top of
the screen we were like what are you
talking about guys from the goddamn
future even if it breaks yeah yeah yeah
I love peeling that off too
man when you get some new electronic
equipment and you peel off you leave it
on at all
for a little bit Yeah you gotta first
couple days week whatever given the
whatever for a little bit now I gotta
rip it off it's the best parts I do like
that but then you feel like it's ruined
right away sure you know can't break the
hymen it's over well there she goes now
she's worthless
in pornography
all right I got one for you what do you
got
I'm a weird guy obviously we're gonna
start off with that
um I let uh the other night uh
uh I went and got a roto
rotisserie chicken yeah shout out to the
Roto
um but there was so much juice in it
like at the bottom you know what I mean
it was like a suspicious amount of
liquid to the playground whatever at it
it's fine but then like I said I've been
alone for
four days or whatever it's been you know
I just let that I closed it I ate you
know I ate it and also sharing a you you
don't you I feel like a real man I
shared it I just sat in the kitchen
eating It sharing it with the dog oh
just throw the one for me one for him we
were a couple of Road dogs dude that was
my best goddamn pal in the world vegan
ninja yeah just like it is good isn't it
buddy hitting it with some skin to
answer you get out of here yeah you've
been a good kid I eat whole squatties
little buddy exactly yeah yeah you gotta
chop up the you gotta chop up the tank
you know what I mean like a Christian
Bale movie Spin this cut son let's go
some loner are you cleaning your gun
while you were doing that
that's how like I yo like I finally
understand like when like Mark
Wahlberg's like you know like the The
Band When the bad guys kill the
superheroes dog or whatever not the
superhero like the you know it happened
like John Wick it happened in shooter
you don't understand they killed my dog
killed the guy rotos come on how's the
guy supposed to eat a roto you kill this
goddamn dog boy uh
uh just straight Roto uh anything on the
side yeah I did uh the place next to me
has like some pre-made green beans
tucked down they're like uh with garlic
and whatever are you eating this did you
portion this are you eating this out of
the little plastic thing it comes in
obviously I'm eating up well and you
didn't eat the whole thing in one
sitting did you yeah I did you did yeah
hold on you ate a whole chicken yeah in
one shot first of all they're barely
chickens they're this is day four a man
alone with his dog dude I've never put
away a roto by myself
I I mean listen here you asked me to pee
on the pocket and you lie to me I never
have dude that's insane I've never eaten
a rotisserie chicken by myself that's
probably one of the reasons why
it's not that much chicken like all all
jokes aside it is not that much chicken
I think if you break the two so it gives
you two chicken breasts they're like
half the size of a chicken breast you
would get at a and it's juicy let's keep
it coming back
that little meat that's like in the in
the juice on the bottom you catch like
the underbelly I don't [ __ ] with that
that's real that's like a coral reef to
me
I'm above board all right I'm mostly
white meat and I don't go I'll go
digging I love that underneath there
take that soft skin off get in there
the skin looks waterlogged down there
looks like a body yeah you needed to be
an insurance adjuster to go down there
too really no I don't [ __ ] with it with
your pen like a detective wow someone
say she flew the coop
I like that chicken cross the road
um My Girl My Girl One Time made uh we
had a roto and took
through rotisserie chicken and made
chicken salad out of it which would have
been awesome but she left his skin on it
by accident
and dude when that [ __ ] gets cold it
turns into pure fact oh yeah it turned
yellow like Yellow fast oh man took a
bite into that sandwich I almost died oh
that's bad news you can't do that but
I've never taken in a room take the skin
off try it takes 10 seconds to eat a
rotisserie chicken I'll do it tonight
yeah
you could are you sitting down you could
not even joking around I mean I could
probably eat
two or three of them there's there's not
there's something weird about eating a
whole chicken though
it's very
what's the word animalistic sure
you're looking coyote
running up on some some guy's Farm you
and Hans just rip
fighting over it okay let's talk about
that Helix mattress baby oh a lot out of
here let's talk about 14 unique
mattresses now you go on the website you
take the quiz whatever matches up best
with you that's what you get here's the
turkey let me tell you this what's that
you know what they also cater to what
big and tall sleepers Big Fellas all you
fatties out there or
string beans
whatever you are if you're a tall drink
of water need a good night's sleep get
over to Helix yeah he looks you can get
the best the best sleep of your life
with Helix uh he'll sleep as a premium
mattress brand that provides tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences like the big man said you
take the two minute sleep quiz me and
the bird took it we got uh set up with
the Twilight mattress I love it we
sprung for the king it's fantastic try
out your new Helix mattress with their
100 night risk-free trial see how your
body adjusts and if it's not the best
fit you can return it for a full refund
because they're good people over there
at Helix he looks he has even been
awarded the number one mattress picked
by GQ and Wired Magazine and talk about
turkey there you go Helix is all
offering up new offer Baby Helix is
offering up to 350 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners one more time run it back not
to take he looks crazy Helix is offering
up to 350 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
Helix sleep.com garbage this is their
best offer yet it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now do it do
it let's talk about mint mobile baby oh
Lord I meant mobile and Ryan Reynolds
about to play a little Hardball over
there he's making moves ladies and
gentlemen couple of special offers going
around throwing around numbers 50 off
this January 15 that get on the deals
gang do yourself a favor if you like
saving money on your phone bill mint
mobile is the plan and the carrier for
you yeah it's a perfect time to switch
but Harry because this 50 off deal ends
January 15. you got a couple of days
anywhere you go get moving here don't
don't be sitting around uh if you buy
any three month plan you'll get three
months for free even on their unlimited
plan all plans come with unlimited
talking Tax Plus the high speed the high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network there you go love
your Karen phone not a problem keep it
as your own phone with a mint Mobile
plan and switch easily in minutes with e
Sim and here we go baby here's the
turkey One More Time by any three month
mint Mobile plan to get three more
months free by going to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at midmobile.com garbage Harry
because that all friends January 15th do
it now back to the show back to the show
yeah but my trash I I got jammed up and
my trash can was full I didn't want to
take that it was like that thing like I
just kept so I started put it in the
fridge I know but I didn't for some
reason you just left a roto out I'll
just let it was sealed that grease firm
up damn for four days until I just threw
it out on the way here was that like
pictures because my wife's coming home
like in like 20 minutes so I'm like I
gotta [ __ ] I walked in this morning
after taking the dog out I was like okay
plus dude it was tight in there and then
I forgot I was cleaning around it like I
would like lift I was like I cleaned the
kitchen it was just moving a rotisserie
chicken around how much how long did it
take you to clean up the evidence of
what you did at the apartment in four
days
all day today a lot it was really it was
a lot
yeah yeah I don't think I went in the
bedroom because I didn't go anywhere I
didn't change I would need guys in
forensic suits to come through yeah how
was the eating other than that pretty
good it was good I mean it was good yeah
yeah I haven't eaten shitty I would I
would say I've had no bread or okay so
car like you know she's been going for
how many days carbs or whatever she's
been going for how many days
four days
so that's how many hours is that 72 96.
so 96 hours how many of those 96 hours
did you spend in your underwear
well I've talked about this a lot I'm in
my underwear most of the time because I
don't like wearing an outside pants
inside we were talking about that with
Ricky Glassman yeah
um so I'm mostly shut up if I'm in the
house I'm in underwear okay so I don't
know 95 hours
[Laughter]
whatever the five minutes isn't going to
get the Roto I had to take the dog out I
mean what do you want for me
yeah no I didn't do much the only thing
that I did was I took him to the uh I
take him down to the water to the tennis
courts and we play you know that was
like the height that was like an hour
total okay the rest of it was rotisserie
chicken and it was rotisserie chicken
frozen cauliflower pizzas and a lot of
diet Dr Pepper
I gotta tell you as far as as the bird
being away that ain't too shabby you
really towed the line I'm grabbing off
of a heavy sure coming off of a heavy
drinking [ __ ] six months I'll tell
you what I was like I'd kill for a
cauliflower pizza the diet Dr Pepper
right now I had two two of the pizzas
yesterday so it wasn't eating well but I
was not eating super who's your brand
California cauliflower oh cauli power
that and I was messing around with some
pre-sliced chorizo as well I I fire up
one of those cauliflower pizzas that I'm
eating I'm just going lie to me baby
tell me I'm doing all right they're good
they're good though tastes great but
they're they're there's a crunchiness on
the bottom oh yeah it's the cauliflower
that's the power of the collie baby
stopping by the grocery store
I just think calorie wise I think
they're like 1500 calories or something
like that Jesus or 900 or something like
that damn they're not yeah that's good
for you it's not a diet yeah it's not
good
but it wasn't too great it wasn't to no
booze that's good I had a Bernie here
and there okay with you okay that's it
all right you know it did all right hey
typically my back when I was you know
gang banging I'd be blacked out drunken
patties every God damn night yeah
whatever
[Laughter]
here
gang as you know when you sign up for
the old patreon you can have your
question read on the air and that's what
we will do right here right now on our
you garbage all right let's start off
with Justin here ten dollar Homie first
time long time is it garbage to use your
passport out of Dave and Buster's as ID
because your license is suspended
can't get in the go-kart
I can't believe I can't play cruising
USA as a dirtbag who's rocked
exclusively the passport because I lost
their ID it does make a great wallet
I'll say that yeah it's like a billfold
yeah put your words I've done it as well
but it's for going International not
going to [ __ ] patties yeah yeah okay
there's a reason you're using it hasn't
been because your behavior has been up
to par you know what I mean you've made
some bad choices if you're showing dude
if you're in Ohio using a passport to
getting Dave and Busters that's a tough
one all right that is bad if it sure if
it sure has no stamps on it yeah yeah
yeah he had to get it because he
couldn't get a license probably yeah
um all right this one's from Jeremy
never had one red do you have any dirty
dishes in your car
that's a tough look and my wife does it
and I [ __ ] I find like a spoon a fork a
mug it makes you feel
how do I put this I got a comforting
feeling when like my dad would drive me
to school and he would go out with his
coffee cup that I it also made for
hilarity when he left it on the
dashboard and hit the game God [ __ ]
damn it back [ __ ] um if you're driving
with it like what do you mean like a
cough like a mug coffee mug from the Hat
when you bring your stuff from the house
it wasn't like a travel it wasn't a
travel mode no it was just a mug but
example that is like homey that is like
Francis Ellis does that remember he told
us yeah and I get that and that is nice
but you hit a pothole or something sure
you know
um can I admit this
please okay if it is the
winter
and
I'm in the car one day if it's not too
if it's not too warm out all right
doesn't have to be like freezing but if
it's you know the fall winter sure
I go on my travels I end up getting a
coffee
okay okay I don't finish the coffee okay
the next day I get back in the car and
that coffee's there what temperature are
we talking I'll pound it ice cold is it
cold enough it's because it can't be
like it can't be balmy it's got to be
cold cold enough to fend off the
bacteria cold enough yeah I'll give you
that I'll do that with a black coffee
and in the winter I don't know if you
remember that big ass [ __ ] it's trash
but I've done it remember that big poem
spring you got me
I left that in there and over Christmas
that thing froze
really I hang a nose a couple of days
ago I [ __ ] found it in there and it
was still a little bit [ __ ] icy
like I was drinking out of the Poland
Spring myself
delicious I'll do that uh yeah I get it
I have I can't do that in the summer
though
once I heard you can't do it in the
summer I just stopped doing it all
together the phenol phenols or whatever
they're called yeah it's too much
plastic they're cold the hot the bot and
I just went no that's just in the summer
sure but I'm going well if it's in the
summer I'm sure whatever's happening it
ain't great for you
just leaving you know
and if there's a soda or something like
that in there I'll have that the next
day too I'll Crush that real quick mix
with the ice sure why not I love how
we're living around here we're not
finishing a soda either I've never had a
rotisserie chicken or soup I don't know
I've never had a whole rotisserie people
are coming and leaving this stuff in
your car
I've never had a whole rotisserie
chicken by myself okay until tonight
send you the video the dead carcass when
you guys were kids and it was super cold
out did you ever make an igloo did you
get enough snow in Philly to do that
I've done that as an adult to go smoke
weed and drink it when we were like 20.
it's the best it's a fun time it's a lot
of construction how do you really make
an igloo you just I think you take a
huge amount of snow yup and then yeah
pack it down and then just dig out the
middle it's not that much construction
at all I never could pull it off dude I
did it at 20 to like just to smoke bombs
[ __ ] yeah it's the greatest I heard the
crazy there's a there's a company in
Russia who's trying to resurrect The
Woolly Mammoth because because their
whole plan is that we need something
real big to pack the snow down to try
and help with the climate change which
seems like the craziest idea
this [ __ ] guy
seems like the most backwards plan ever
to be yeah we need to bring back woolly
mammoth so they can be our Zamboni boom
Dino DNA is that is that a real thing
yes dude where did you read Russians or
kooky man
where did you read something like that
hey I'll tell you I'll tell you wild all
right well you're doing that well you're
over in [ __ ] crazyville we'll keep
moving on yeah uh all right this one's
from Peter ever cried a concert
yeah the menzinger's concert bawling my
eyes out oh really oh yeah oh right
right right Anna yeah whoo got me good
we were as good you ran out of Bud
Lights
okay yeah I gotta tell you the the first
website isn't great it's The Intercept
which that doesn't sound right that is
yeah but then the NPR New York Times
it's real dude the CIA investigate
invested in it too invested it's a real
cold one I guess if you're gonna bring
back a [ __ ] woolly mammoth we gotta
be you know we have to have eyes on it
you just can't be letting other people
bring it back the US has to be like a
little bit over it's got to bring back
our woolly mammoth all right then we'll
[ __ ] we're gonna have a mammoth all
for something give them passports and
send them over
um that makes sense I'll give you that
they want to bring back the woolly
mammoth so it can walk around and pat
down the snow yes
[ __ ] Mass Russians hey what do away
hey what are you getting the [ __ ] kicked
out of here you [ __ ] idiots leave
that all right
listen they're gonna get bored in
Ukraine and [ __ ] turn their sights to
30s I don't need that I don't need to be
fighting a land War all right I got the
IRS breathing down my neck I'll take
that smoke
um all right let's see here uh this is
from Austin never have one red are you
garbage if you order a round of Fireball
shots for the table at a fancy
Steakhouse
depends when in the meal I think no all
right listen shots at a restaurant are
typically a bad look although I as soon
as I say that I've done I've finished
the table no that's shots of Fireball
do you ever have Sambuca
that's different no it's not that's
recipient not for shooting yeah and it's
an after dinner liqueur Fireball is not
an after dinner liquor it could be the
three jail liquor okay
hahaha get out of here you're wrong I
love Fireball right before you jump onto
a folding table in a Bills game I love
it but there's no way is it classy but
it could be
that's all marketing dude it wasn't
Fireball that's all marketing that's all
marketing if you put that in some cool
Italian bottle and brought that on the
sommelier brought that over imported it
he's not imported in like those little
mini sniffles wasn't its thing it would
be something else yeah I understand that
if I wasn't your dad I'd be your sister
at its heart though whatever that
they're saying is shut up what's that
saying if my mom if my mom was my mom
she'd be my aunt or something like that
I have no idea you're a hillbilly what
is it if my aunt had a dick she'd be my
uncle yeah Elder called me back to
dinner if after the meal when the
espresso and the dessert's going around
I think a fireball shot would mix in
there with the cinnamon flavor I can I
kind of see you're making it but it's
not it is one of as a guy who looked
down my Barrel I love it Fireball got me
through like a decade it's fantastic but
you should there's a time and a place
and that is not at a state house it's
not a dinner unless you're a friendlies
or something like that like that I
wonder if steak and some steakhouses
even have that and I I guarantee if you
go into Gallagher's and order it you're
uh do you think Gallagher says Fireball
only one way to find out boys
yeah there's no way
there's no way I don't think also I
don't think shots shots at dinner shots
aren't for dinner shots are for a bar
it's shots at dinner you're not supposed
to do that and any Season Pro would know
that you get a whiskey on the Rocks
that's like two shots there no cause
they're gonna charge it the shots aren't
they're going to be expensive shots to
begin with
and I've done it at like Bachelor
parties you go out whatever uh uh and
you're at like a steakhouse we do like
shots of you know around the shots or
whatever that's a little different
because that's like a
celebrate it's like you're supposed to
be an idiot at a [ __ ] bachelor party
type thing
um all right let's see here uh staying
in restaurants this is from Pat is it
garbage to bring an outside cake to a
restaurant for a birthday especially if
they have cake on the menu at the
restaurant wait a minute I'll defer to
you yes okay
uh no not at all that's actually the
classier of the move unless you're
calling ahead and having the pastry this
is a real nice joint if we're not we're
not I mean you know we're not you're not
gonna call ahead we're not talking real
nice joints not a place that's gonna
make you a cake okay all right hold on
let me understand because
I assume they don't have like full like
a whole full cake to give you it's like
this pre-sliced [ __ ] they do they do but
they would bang you over the head and
probably charge you buy the slice that's
what I'm saying like you're getting like
a seven dollar slice for 12 people yeah
you're getting a 70 cheesecake yeah
which is which they tried to do that to
us one time uh for my brother's uh 30th
birthday party we forgot about the cake
and we're like do you guys have a cake
here she's like some Irish [ __ ] broad
she's like I don't have to charge you
for the slice it was like 120 cheesecake
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah she told you
though she gave you the heads up sure
you can't get mad at her but no we've
done that a bunch we'll do that you call
ahead because if it's a big group too
it's like we're gonna bring a cake for
30 people call ahead we're gonna bring
in the cake after uh don't they charge
like a cotton female
and a little plating fee big deal I
never mind it as a server because you
got to play real nice with the family
and they tip heavy yeah you bring it out
all right we'll take it back we'll cut
it do you guys want to cut it here we
can bring you some plates we can bring
it with this we do some coffees or
anything like that if anybody wants
anything maybe a fireball shot some
sambuca they're really pushing that
um
you girls 21.
plus it was always good for a fat kid
most times they didn't take that [ __ ]
with them oh no you're not you're not
taking a quarter of a cake
that in the back and chop that up at the
Busboys
like you're at like he just like he just
robbed the plug eating in the walk-in a
little dude man that regular [ __ ]
birthday cake icing catch that around
the corner oh call me crazy
all right let's keep her moving here uh
um all right this is from suit guy do
you take videos on your phone during a
drive-through car wash
you can't say it ain't a good time
that's one of those things when you're
experiencing it you go everybody needs
to feel this everybody's got to see what
I'm saying because it is a unique thing
to be a part of especially now because
they they go real colorful with the
lights and stuff with the lights but
also the the the things that they put on
the car it looks like Silly String
getting put on the windshield I mean
when I was a kid I used to love that
[ __ ] you could be the hardest man on the
planet and you'll giggle like a school
girl if you go through a car wash with a
dog in the car
I know what I'm doing later losing it I
[ __ ] love it dude
I remind you I went to I went to one of
those like self-clean
Johns where you like you know clean out
hair and blood from your drunk after
you've killed somebody with the power
washers you win wow I had to I needed a
vacuum because [ __ ] the dog's hair is
all over the back of the seat
uh after we went at this like it was we
got off the highway somewhere there's a
place out by you up that way up towards
Bucks County
um Carl's or something where it's free
vacuuming
and it's like five bucks to get the wash
oh yeah let's check it out do your
windows while someone changes the plates
on their car
someone steals your hubcaps the [ __ ]
it's not driving that part of town
[ __ ] doing hot swaps at the
self-watch dude
and we'll scrape the VIN off for seven
dollars extra
taking my car to get clean to the Chop
Shop dude
did you want our complimentary hair
bleaching
and fake passport service are you gonna
need an alibi or not sir what the [ __ ]
craziest thing catalytic converter fell
right off now you didn't have a cataloo
converter when you brought that in here
did you sir Mr Ryan this is Dave he was
with you all night
as far as anybody knows
Carl's self-washing Alabama
[Laughter]
here's your two fake movie tickets
that's good stuff ah but yeah it's just
like in that that place man it's just
like a different set of characters at
one of those self-cleaned shorts
how are you using the gun what how are
you using the gun I just was vacuuming
okay I just went for the vacuum I wasn't
letting them [ __ ]
I wasn't going to get vulnerable in that
place and get caught you know what I
mean you got that gun in your hand now
that power washer yeah you feel pretty
blow somebody's brains but I did find it
weird they were selling like you go and
they had like a crazy set of [ __ ]
like wall vending machines not like
snack vending machines but like the ones
on the walls you know what I mean you
can get like air fresheners you can get
like Armor All wipes it was like a huge
selection they also had condoms I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on here getting
laid what do you mean I gotta spell this
out for you those guys watching our own
cars they close deals bro [ __ ] men
there to clean all the semen off yeah
have you have you ever used a pressure
washer outside of that yeah yeah I've
ruined a bunch of decks because I didn't
know the I didn't know like I was like
nine my dad's like power washed the deck
I'm like all right
[ __ ] man I almost took my brother's
toe off dude he came home upset
I really I ruined they just got the pool
too
like it did and then he was like power
walk because it was like muddy because
like the construction and he's like
power washing again I was like nine we
just got a power washer and I ruined it
it was like two it's fine yeah it's too
fine and it just takes the finish off I
was like writing my name and stuff
you don't give a nine-year-old a power
washer
Come From a Different Cloth my neighbor
had one and I was like I think that
thing's crazy he was like oh crazy a
little earlier today blew a hole in a
rat
it's pretty good
it's pretty good it's a good time rat
ran across blew a whole clean through
him
power washers power washers snow blowers
weed whackers
all pretty fun times I'll be honest with
you oh yeah sit down lawnmower that's
not good with any of them really hello I
mean lump dude I'm a [ __ ] surgeon
with a [ __ ] trimmer I just never
cared I'll get too close because it was
always like every time I we had to cut I
had to cut the grass every week growing
up and it was like
all my friends were already doing
something so I'm like [ __ ] and I had put
it off so they're like we're going to
the movies at seven and I'm like it's
like 6 15. I gotta get the whole yard
done and trimmed and bagged I'm cutting
some [ __ ] corners now
I gotta go strike out with some chicks
at the mall oh dude
Landscaping in the summer uh high school
and college it would just be like me and
the two owners and they would be on like
the the riding ones and they'd send me a
head like a four caddy into the
neighborhood just [ __ ] edging [ __ ]
then I'd loop back around with the
blower
man put my ten thousand hours in on that
[ __ ] I'll tell you that got real
good I had to cut a huge field for my
stepdad's Dad I'm like I'll give you 100
bucks or something I should probably
told this and I just wore it was like
June or July or something I just wore a
basketball jersey like no undershirt I
was like I'll get a tan I was going down
the shore
10 hours on that thing in an open field
not a tree in sight dude I'm gonna go
ahead and ruin the next two weeks of my
life you have no idea dude I was crying
I had blisters like this big all over my
shoulders oh [ __ ] suck dude it was
not worth the hundred you put a little
50 on or something nothing Well
Coppertone after that that's why like I
mean like it is like a at the bar
peeling
saw blade ladies
we used to do it with our shirt off all
summer with no [ __ ]
uh Sun sunscreens it's crazy there's a
hole in a goddamn ozone you can't do
that no more crazy back when kids could
be kids crazy it's all the hairspray
your generation right yeah hold on Aqua
Net as a dude who's never dyed his hair
what's the plan are you gonna it has
it's currently some of it still dies
yeah but he's gonna let it grow out till
it's just tips yeah
I'm not gonna die it back okay Summer's
almost here bro about to double down I
just had my first Diet Mountain Dew this
summer what are you talking about
tighten up this body a little bit and
hit the boards you've got the tightest
flow on the show bro uh
all right let's see here
um
this is from cam never have one red is a
garbage to always wear a pair of
basketball shorts under any pair of
pants she
she I've done it in a pinch for sure
gotta be skinny to pull that off
or ready to go yeah we're ready to
[ __ ] we're headed to the Rucker or
something you got to be ready to [ __ ]
Run game dude shorts
under pants
I could never do that
I'm sure you've done it at some point
but you gotta explain this to me
underwear if you are missing certain
things that I don't understand hold on
underwear basketball shorts and then
like jeans or maybe just basketball yeah
or maybe just basketball shorts as
underwear I don't know I'm reading the
settings I have the same information you
have and most people's pants have the
structural Integrity to handle some
basketball shorts which I don't think
you do I couldn't they couldn't get in
there
you have to be a cat burglar to get in
there
[Laughter]
yeah I've done it yeah we I mean yeah
we've talked about it because remember
there's that picture I just saw the
picture it's in my [ __ ] garage
where's the Ambrose yes I almost took a
picture of it dude there's a white
string hanging straight down my black
cords
at my grandparents 50th wedding
anniversary man
soccer shorts so that's different I'm
thinking basketball shorts I'm thinking
like heavy thick basketball shorts sure
but they make I think mesh shorts are
also just basketball shorts and not all
men shorts are that are that thick you
got to be in good shape I would argue
you gotta be gonna be tight body for
that one yeah for athletic wear yeah
that and those joggers like the the thin
joggers like the
like actual like you wear like khaki
joggers talking about the gun show what
talk about the gun shows what do you
mean some Thin joggers yeah your meat
just hanging out you got to be in shape
to pull those off oh yeah of course yeah
that's why I go khaki yeah somewhere
respectable yeah yeah I can't just wear
sweatpants I know they're joggers on an
In-Shape person they're sweatpants on a
fat guy yeah yeah or long underwear
depends depends how tight they are some
of those just turn into spandex real
quick man I used to hate long underwear
as a kid long johns getting [ __ ]
putting that [ __ ] on I feel like I
worked in the panhand I didn't
understand I felt like I'm putting them
on was like so like you went back in
time people today aren't still waiting
there has to be better technology than
these [ __ ] waffle pants look at that
you got the bud flap the crotch was so
low it's like it was meant to have a
load of [ __ ] in it it was so low it like
started at the knees yeah you can't
[ __ ] have that
the khakis are good but they rat you out
about a p dribble real quick
sure I got one buddy I'm not gonna name
them but it may or may not have been on
the patreon
may or may not be in this room right now
dude every Heap he wears khakis all the
time and just constant he goes I'll go
to the bathroom I'll be right and he
comes out he's like half peed himself
every single and ends up in pictures his
his girl's tagging him in pics and [ __ ]
and we just we just screenshot it and
zoom in on it why tough look yeah as you
get older it drips it's a tough look for
me well if you got it if you got a
decent piece it's okay because that's
good advertising it lets you know where
the end yeah yeah mine's above my belt
buckle that's no bueno are you lactating
I see that guy over there he's got a
deep dribble
it's down by his knees
[ __ ] pee stains on my shirt
my little noodle
[Laughter]
poor little guy tough oh lizard tough
look haha
sure The Jig Is up you know what I mean
when they catch you with a pee Staying
High up top I know yeah there's no
there's no coming back there's no coming
back from that no uh all right this
one's from Chris and the more lies to be
told
that's physics got you dead the rights
talk about all the cards on the tables
it's all gone the stains don't lie this
no no I doubled up
hahaha
yeah that's just water I was splashing
it I gotta cool them off a little bit
some other little dick guy who's wearing
my pants I swear
laughs
he stole them I made him take him off he
went to the I don't know just you know
ah man all right uh this one's from
Chris it's the garbage to watch the free
YouTube apps at 1.25 playback speed but
the paid patreon ones at normal because
I want to get my money's worth
dude when people they listen to the
podcast on one and a half speeds it's
wild it's like
crazy it's like Tron to me dude I don't
know how you do it I I don't know
whatever you gotta do to get it in you
you know what I'm saying you're [ __ ]
main line in it
buddy try
to meditate something dude if you're
crushing times to anything
that's too much information at one time
this is a quick moving show to begin
with sure we're bebopping and Scott
bebopping and scatting so that's like
man this guy's gonna that hurts my head
thinking about it it's a lot man
um all right let's see here this one's
from Shamir ten dollar euro homie here
we go
stay strong over there brother what
uh never have one read it how many
crimes have you witnessed from your
bedroom window I've seen some things
from a guy getting one punch KO pretty
cool to a guy getting dragged out of his
car and stabbed that's cool yikes I
don't think I've ever seen anything get
on Zillow will you a couple of spots
around yeah never but that's what you'd
I look out my window or like a hotel or
anything you always want to see you want
to see something juicy I'd spring into
action again [ __ ] I couldn't just let
that go down
what would you do so right now you're on
the what floor of your building say I'm
on the eighth floor okay I parkour down
to the department I do a half Gainer out
the window
you're holy [ __ ]
yeah hey run out to the hallway I yanked
the fire hose out I tied that up spin
that around yeah
I'll be right there if it wasn't to walk
up
you're lucky you didn't try this in an
elevator building I'm gonna call the
cops in a couple minutes it's waiting on
free nights it depends what it was
I definitely go down there and help them
after the bad guys were gone I wouldn't
just sit there yeah of course I'm also a
[ __ ]
dude I just bring it I'd film it on my
phone yeah dude I'd make sure we'd have
documented video for the authorities and
I wouldn't film it I'd go down there
yeah straight somebody out I don't think
I've ever
witnessed anything no especially I saw a
boob one time from my old apartment that
was pretty cool I've seen that yeah
seen people boning really yeah I don't
think I've ever seen any I thought we
saw people boning when we were in L.A
for across the street from the store
that apartment complex
what their people banging in the window
upstairs oh was that yeah unless it was
kind of a dream or something then maybe
or maybe somebody filmed it but we were
actually we were standing there at one
point
I forget but that does sound familiar
right I do remember seeing legs there
was legs up in the air damn some guys
are saying I bet you he had a low P
stain you know he washes his own car
I saw the world's slowest fight outside
of a bar in Chicago one time three
o'clock in the afternoon two 60 year old
men blind drunk chasing each other
around a car at about half a mile an
hour dude
you get hurt
I forget what they called it but uh a
relative of mine will just Loosely say
that as an older gentleman and he went
he got big on not big he got in a fight
with another old guy the tumble and the
something if it was on Barstool it was
on World Star you know him yeah he's
related to me he's in my family was down
in Wildwood
he win uh if you talk to him he did
see it's called like Wildwood fight or
wild one it's two old guys fighting it
outside of a car
I don't know it was on bars you're done
pulling things up don't worry don't
worry I kicked it to him and I was like
all right maybe or not just find
anything type in Mike Tyson
just find any fight ever to happen
there's a lot of fights of Wildwood none
of them are old guys yeah there it is
also I want to we should do a week a
week down the shore I think a week yeah
let's do a week down the shore it'll be
like today's vacation you know how they
do okay spring break and everything like
the spring break house we'll have tudy's
house down the shore for a week okay
we'll go down slow down we'll just do
the beach we'll do a bunch of apps we'll
have some homies come down cool film it
a little bit of this a little bit of
that a lot of dollies snooky we gotta do
Wildwood right Snooki uh Snooki can come
sure no what do you have questions on
Wildwood we're gonna go to [ __ ]
Avalon I don't think we can afford Apple
under Stone armor kid laugh us out of
town get beat up by a bunch of Lacrosse
guys
the last thing I need to get beat up
with people with crabs on their pants
some lobsters on this shirt some dick
head and a duck belt I'll fight a guy in
a Tapout shirt for sure
some guy in a salmon Polo oh yeah
yeah kicking the [ __ ] out of here some
guy in an ass got kicking the [ __ ] out
of me of course I won nothing Terrible's
ever happened in my life
that's good
um all right let's do uh one more here
hit me
um all right this one's from Jerry new
homie never had one red is a garbage to
attend an EDM festival at the local
Wilkes-Barre ski resort slash water park
those mountain people give me the
heebie-jeebies shout out to wilkesbury
Pennsylvania yeah you're a mountain
person a place of my birth my friend
yeah yeah as a home birth right
dude at the General Store where'd you do
that it was outside but
right there in the driveway
um now born in Mountaintop Pennsylvania
born in wilkesbury I think first house
Mountaintop pa
um I mean I think if you're going to uh
EDM EDM is what electric dance music
okay I get that in DDT confused or
whatever it's called DMT ah one's a
wrestling moves one hard drug yeah all
right so DDT is it is the dtp is Diamond
Dallas Page and he would do the DDT I
believe Diamond Cutter well I'm an
[ __ ] the DDT was another move I
believe but I believe his move was the
Diamond Car DDT was also some kind of
pesticide or something like that too I
don't know what you country folk were
doing up there yeah there was a there
was a pesticide DDT don't have them look
it up he's still looking up this will be
easy
that's how the internet works
nose is running uh oh
diclopter octane yeah commonly known as
DDT is colorless tasteless and the most
odorless crystalline chemical compound
and organic chloride God I'm dumb uh
yeah it's an excessive side yeah
I get those mixed up and then dmt's the
stuff you take and it really [ __ ] up
the environment yeah dmt's the stuff you
think you get all [ __ ] up yeah it'll
do I'm pretty sure if you take some DDT
I don't [ __ ] yeah I don't have I don't
have I don't have the research on it
putting the weeds out if you need some I
know a guy
so he goes to he goes to an EDM concert
yeah
and what at a ski resort slash water
park up there okay off season at a ski
resort is a tough look yeah dry Hills
probably at like Camel Beach or
something okay Camelback Camelback but
in the summer it's Camel Beach is that
really yeah what do they they have
something up there yeah they have a
water park really I didn't know that I
believe yeah huh Toby don't go look it
up I want to check that out that Great
Wolf Lodge too yeah looks pretty legit
oh cool didn't get all [ __ ] up yeah
that's wild
um yeah it's a bad
also I don't think Skrillex and [ __ ]
you know and Diplo are going to the or
going to the Gray Wolf Lodge in
Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania you got to be
getting like the the new guys get a
couple of tickets to Ibiza dude what are
you doing yeah get out of there that's a
tough love can't listen to that [ __ ] in
a [ __ ] go-kart you're on the ski lift
uh we gotta wrap it up gang gang we love
you to death love yous we will see you
next week a peace peace